S
I KNOW YOU ARE KEEPING TRACK
TODAY MARKS TWELVE WEEKS SINCE
WE PASSED THE HEROES ACT- IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES A
BILL TO OPEN UP OUR ECONOMY BY
TESTING TRACING TREATING. MASS
SANITATION DISTANCING AND THE
REST. THAT UNDER TO HEROES SO
CALLED BECAUSE THEY ARE RISKING
THEIR LIVES TO SAVE LIVES AND
NOW THEY MAY BE THEIR JOB BACK
MILLION HAVE. THAT WILL I'VE
ALREADY THAT WOULD HEALTH
WORKERS THERE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND TEACHERS ARE
SANITATION CHECKED TO WERE WHO
ARE ALL EMPLOYEES EIGHT VOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE DATE OF THE
CONTRACT ONE ETHNIC. ALL RIGHT
LET. TWO KANNST BUT IT ALSO A
THERE PROJECTED THE POINT SIX
MILLION MORE LAID OFF IN THE IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD UNLESS WE DO
SOMETHING TO PROTECT OUR HEROES
WE LOSE ALL. AND SAID. AND
MONEY. DONALD AND THEN THIRD TO
PUT MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE- IT'S ABOUT THE
IDEA THE LIVELIHOOD THE LIFE OF
OUR DEMOCRACY SO WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THE FENCE IS POSTAL
SERVICE. DETECTION LEFT SHINS
SAY. FACED WITH OSHA AND THE
REST HELLO AT THAT TIME IN THAT
TWELVE WEEKS THAT YOU REMEMBER
THAT RIGHT THEN AND THERE WHEN
WE PASSED THE BILL OF THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER IN THE SENATE
WAS. WE NEED BECAUSE- PUSHED
APART BUTTON HE PUSHED THE
PAUSE BUTTON IN THAT PERIOD OF
TIME IN THESE OF WEEK. THAT IN
HALF MILLION. HAVE BEEN
INFECTED ADDED TO THE ROLLS OF
THOSE INFECTED. SEVENTEEN
MILLICH SKEWS ME SEVENTY
THOUSAND HAVE DIED. SEVENTY
THOUSAND IN THESE- TWELVE WEEKS.
THREE AND THREE AND A HALF
MILLION INFECTED. THEN LAST HE
COMES BACK FINALLY FROM THE
POLICY OF WITH A PIECEMEAL
PROPOSAL THAT DOES NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WELL WE HAVE BEEN AT MY DESK
TRYING TO FIND COMMON GROUND
ACT COLLEGES HARDLY VALUES ARE
SO DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF BUBBLE
UP FROM THE WORKING CLASS THAT.
THE END. FOR ABOUT. MR I OUGHT
TO THEM WE'LL DOWN A TRILLION
IF YOU ADD A TRILLION END. THEY
SAID ABSOLUTELY NOT IF WE COULD
DO THAT IF WE TAKE DOWN A
TRILLION AND THEY ADDED
TRILLIANT WILL WITHIN EACH.
WE'LL BE WITHIN RANGE BUT WE
MUST MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WE COULD COME
DOWN SOME BECAUSE WE CAN.
CHANGE THE DATES OF EXPIRATION
THE REST OF THAT BUT NOT
UNDERMINE OUR PRIORITIES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. AND IT IS AN- YOUR
PLACE AGAIN WE BELIEVE INSIDE.
AND GOVERNANCE IN TERMS OF-
INTERESTING THAT THE VIRUS THAT
WE NEED TO DO AND THAT'S HOW
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN OUR
ECONOMY. IN TERMS OF THE
LIVELIHOODS OF. WE'RE HONORED
OUR HEROES. THAT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR OUR ECONOMY TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE UNEMPLOYMENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY ARE OUR
HEROES SAFE SCHOOLS WE ARE
DIFFERENT PLACE BECAUSE WE ARE
OF. LISTENING TO- WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'RE TELLING US SLOW LARGELY
THEY WANT TO HAVE- VIRTUAL. AT
THE HUNDRED TOP THE LARGEST OF
THE- SCHOOL DISTRICTS SET OVER
SIXTY SAID THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE OF ALL VIRTUAL SOME A
HYBRID VERY FEW ACTUALLY IN
PERSON SCHOOL WE WANT AS MANY
KIDS AS POSSIBLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL BUT WE HAVE TO GET SAFE
TO SELL. IN SECURITY GOES ON
AND ON I WROTE TO MY COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THIS TODAY YOU'VE
PROBABLY SEEN THAT THIS IS
ABOUT I SEE EVERYTHING THROUGH
THE EYES OF THE CHILDREN. WE
NEED TO. THE HOUSE INSECURE. WE
CAN'T HAVE OUR TO. BE HUNGRY
CAN'T THEM BE. A WHOLE AND WE
CANNOT HAVE THEM BE. TO SCHOOL.
AND IF WE ARE GOING TO BE TO
MORE PEOPLE GO TO WORK. WE NEED
CHILDCARE IT'S ALL OF THESE
ABOUT CHILDREN FROM THE SO
AGAIN OF WE'LL BE NEEDING
AFTERNOON. AND I WILL BEGIN
MAKE THE- OFFER WELCOME DOWN.
ONE TRILLION AND THEN. HEALTH
WILL BE RANGE OF A EACH UP.
THERE AGAIN AT THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT SET VALUE ACROSS THE
TEN. TRICKLE DOWN. BOTTLE UP.
DISTINGUISH LEADER FROM
DESTRUCTION PROBABLY NOT. WELL
FOR YOU OOPS SENATE. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH SPEAKER ONE AGAIN FOR
YOUR STRAW PASS NOW LEAVE. BUT
LET ME JUST SAY WE SAW THE J.
WERE. AND IT'S CLEAR THE
ACCOUNT. IS LOSING STEAM. THAT
ME WE NEED BIG BOLD INVEST IN
TO HELP AT FOLKS. AND WHEN THE
ECONOMY STARTS TO LOSE GROUND.
THE ONLY CHOICE IS FOR A STRONG
PACKAGE. AND YET. AT TIMES
YESTERDAY OUR REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS SEEM WILLING TO WALK
AWAY FROM THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
TO DO ON WORKABLE WEEK IN
NARROW EXECUTIVE ORDERS WHICH
ARE NOT GOING TO DO THE JOB FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO NEGOTIATE. AND AS
WE SAID WE ARE WILLING TO MAKE
COMPROMISES. WE SEE WITH OUR
BILL HEROES BILLETED THREE FOUR
THERE'S IS THAT ONE. SO THE
SPEAKER MADE A VERY FAIR OFFER.
LET'S NARROW IT EACH AND YOU
SHOULD HAVE SEEN THE VEHEMENCE
NO I SAID YOU MEAN AFTER SHE
SAID IT WILL GO DOWN TO
TRILLION YOU GO UP A TRILLION.
WE CAN SEE. WHERE OR WHEN AND
IT'S MAINLY IN TERMS OF STATE'S
BUT THAT'S OKAY. AND YOU SHOULD
HAVE SEEN THEIR FACES
ABSOLUTELY NOT I SAID YOU MEAN
WE YOU WANT IT TO GO ALMOST ALL
IN YOUR DIRECTION OR YOU WON'T
OKAY THEY SAID YEAH. WE ARE
TRYING TO COMPROMISE. THE SPIN
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING ON THAT WE
HAVEN'T MOVED OFFICE. BY WHAT
HAPPENED. THEY ARE THE ONE STOP
YOU MAY SAY BASICALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS. MR MEADOWS FROM
THE TEA PARTY YOU HAVE TWENTY
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
GREATLY INFLUENCED THEM. AND
THEY WANT TO SPEND THE
NECESSARY DOLLARS TO HELP GET
AMERICA OUT OF THIS MESS
IDEOLOGY. SORT OF BLINDS. SO WE
NEED A BILL THEY'RE ONLY REALLY
TWO CHOICES FOR OUR REPUBLICAN
NEGOTIATING FRANCE. THEY CAN DO
A STRONG BILL. WITH DEMOCRATS
AND THEY HAVE TO REALIZE.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED A MAJORITY
THEY'RE IN NEED ALL THE
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR IT IN THE
HOUSE AND A MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR IN THE
SENATE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
VOTES IN THE SENATE. SO THAT
MEANS YOU NEED US. MOVING I
CAN'T JUST SAY NO WHEN DO IT
OUR WAY. WERE THERE OTHER
CHOICE IS TO DO SOME WEEK
INSUFFICIENT EXECUTIVE ORDERS
THAT JUST WON'T DO THE JOB FOR
THE P. WE ALL WANT TO HELP.
IT'S NOT THAT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS MIGHT BE NEGATIVE BUT
THEY'RE TOTALLY INSUFFICIENT.
THEY'RE INSUFFICIENT IN TWO
WAYS WHAT THEY DO. IT'S
DIFFICULT BECAUSE IN BECAUSE IT
SEEMS AND NO ONE KNOWS WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO. BUT THEY
CAN'T SPEND MONEY THEY CAN ONLY
FORWARD MUCH. SO IF YOU DO A
PAYROLL TAX CUT THEN AFTER
WHATEVER MET WITH AFTER IT
EXPIRES BOTH BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS HAVE A HUGE PAYMENT TO
MAKE. YOU DO ONE EMPLOYMENT AND
YOU LAY IN THE STATE'S MONEY.
THEIR STOCK THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY THEY MAY NOT WANT TO DO
IT. IN TERMS OF TENANTS YEAH
DELANEY. FICTIONS IS NECESSARY
BUT NOT SO. BECAUSE ONCE THOSE
ONCE THE DELAY IS OVER.
DETENIDOS A TREMENDOUS OF MONEY
AND BY THE WAY THE LANDLORD BE
A FORMER SMALL LITTLE LANDLORDS
HAVEN'T GOTTEN PAID AND THEY
CAN'T PAY THEIR MORE IS IN
THEIR BILLS. AND THERE'S A
FOURTH ONE. AND THE COLLEGE
LOANS IS DEFERRAL. SO YOU DON'T
PAY FOR A FEW MONTHS AND THEN
YOU HAVE MORE TO PAY IT IS MUCH
BETTER. THERE ARE. NEEDED THAT
YESTERDAY. TO DO A STRONG
ROBUST BILL BUT THEY SEEM
UNABLE BUT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WITH THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS IS AN
WHAT THEY DO. THEY LEAVE OUT.
THEY LOOK WE KNOW WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
ECONOMICALLY UNTIL WE SOLVE THE
HEALTH PROBLEMS AND SPEAKERS
BEEN. LIKE EIGHT. LYONESSE SIX
IN OUR LINE LINE OKAY HAS BEEN
LIKE A LION S. IN PURSUING THIS
AT EVERY MEETING WE HAVE BEEN
AT. AND YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
CURE THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THEY STILL
SEEM UNWILLING. TO DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR A STRONG TESTING
TRACING AND TREATMENT REGIME.
WHAT IS ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEM
FACING US IN THE NEXT AS THE
SPEAKER MENTION SCHOOL. OPEN UP
THIS CALL SAFETY DA. SCHOOL
YOU'RE GONNA BE A- BECAUSE LOTS
OF PEOPLE CAN'T GO TO WORK.
THANK YOU ORDERS TO LEAVE OUT
SCHOOL ALL TOGETHER. STATE AND
LOCAL SEARCH. THEY CAME A TINY
BIT AND DIRECTION ON THAT BUT
VERY LITTLE NOT IN THE MORE
CLOSED WHAT. YOU CAN'T DO THAT
BY EXECUTIVE ORDER IT SPENDING
AND YOU'LL HAVE FIREFIGHTERS
THIS IS NOT ABSTRACT THIS IS
NOT. GOVERNMENT IT IS
FIREFIGHTERS SANITATION WORKERS
BUS DRIVERS HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WHO NEED TO GET PAID. ELECTIONS.
I GOT EXCITED FOR FIRM. AT
MEETING YESTERDAY THIS IS THE
WELLSPRING OF OUR IT'S NOT MUCH
MONEY. WE NEED THE MONEY TO
HELP STATES IN COVID CONDUCT
ELECTIONS WHEN SO MUCH MORE IS
GOING TO BE BY MAIL AND EVEN
WHEN YOU BOLTON PERSON YOU NEED
MORE POLLING PLACE WHY THEY
RESISTED. IT'S A SMALL AMOUNT
WE'VE ASKED FOR THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE- HEROES
ACT. IT'S NOT THE MONEY. THEY
ALMOST SEEM THEY DON'T WANT
ELECTIONS TO BE CONDUCTED. IN A
FULL WAY IS POSSIBLE THEY SEEM
THAT THEY WANT CERTAIN PEOPLE
NOT TO BE ALMOST GUARDING THEM
FROM BEING ABLE TO BUILD STOP
THIS. THERE WAS SET. A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON THAT. AND FRANKLY
WE HAVE LITTLE FAITH THAT
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
POLITICIZE THE POST OFFICE AND
WE NEED LANGUAGE IN LEGISLATION
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S NOT THE
ABSTRACT THEY DON'T LIKE HAVING
A GOOD POST OFFICES YES ON.
IT'S PEOPLE GETTING THEIR
MEDICINES. IT'S DURING COVID
AGRADABLE. ON IT AND IT'S
ELECTIONS. IF THE BALLOTS ARE
NOT SENT QUICKLY ENOUGH IF BOTH
HE- ABSENTEE BALLOTS THE
APPLICATION FOR MAIL BALLOTS.
AND THE BALLOTS THEMSELVES ARE
DELAYED TOO MUCH WE WON'T HAVE
A FAIR ELECTION. WE TALKED
ABOUT FOOD ASSISTANCE. THEY DO
NOT WANT TO DO WHAT'S NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE KIDS AND OTHERS DON'T
GO HUNGRY. WE TALKED ABOUT
UTILITY SHUT OFFS. IF YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A MORATORIUM ON RENT
BUT PEOPLE CAN'T PAY THEIR
ELECTRIC BILLS THEIR WATER
BILLS THEIR HOMES AREN'T. THAT
WOULD. SO AND WE TALKED ABOUT
TARGETED AIDE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO MANY
THINGS ARE LEFT OUT. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IT IS THIS IS A
FLOOD. ECONOMICALLY AND HEALTH
WISE OF BIBLICAL PROPORTION AND
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS ARE LOOKING
LIKE THEY JUST WANT TO FIX A
LEAKY FAUCET THAT'S WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE HERE. WE'LL NEED TO
AMERICA. HAVE REAL NEEDS THE
PUBLIC IS ON OUR SIDE. BUT THEY
BE SEEN NOT TO BE WILLING TO GO
IN A DIRECTION. THAT WOULD MEET
THOSE NEEDS AND INSTEAD. GET A
IS THAT ONE COMPANY TO DOING
THE JOB THAT IS NEEDED. SPEAKER
AS A LEADER WAS OUT THINKING OF
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FED IN THE
NATION HE HAS GIVEN US TO THINK
BIG AT. TWO UP MORE. THAT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD FOR THE WHY
CAN'T DO MORE TO SHORE UP THE
MASS WORKING FOR. THIS IS THE
AT THE MOMENT WHERE IS THE MORE
SHOULD BE A REAL US. CAUTIONARY
CALL TO SAY. MOMENTUM IS. THE
MEMBER CAN WHICH- I'M
GOVERNMENT INVESTS. FROM WHAT
WE DID THE PRE BILL THAT KEPT
THE ECONOMY GO. THAT PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE MONEY THEIR POCKET
WOULD NOT. HAVE COME. WE SPEND
JET IN DEMAND INTO ENEMY THANK
JOHN. WE SEE THAT SLOWING DOWN.
EVERY WHO TALK TO US FROM THE
AT AND YET WORLD AND ALL THE
ARE SEN DICK PAY NOW OR PAY
LATER. THIS IS YOUR HOME PAGE
LATER. YOU'RE GONNA PAY LATER
AFTER. NOT THE IN A BIG WAY. MR
LEADER. ARNOLD TOYNBEE ARNOLD
TWENTY IN HIS HISTORIES OF
CIVILIZATION AS YOU. ARE AWARE
OF HE SAID THAT- ONE SOCIETIES
OR FORMS. THERE ARE TWO WAYS
THEY CAN GO. THE ELITE MINORITY
THAT WILL BE ROLLING OF COULD
BE THERE CALLED THE FLOWERING
AT LEAST THERE FOR THE
FLOWERING OF EVERY THOUGHT. AT
THE SITE OR- SIX WHAT
MINORITIES AND THEY'RE THERE
FOR POWER AND MONEY. HELLO AND
WHEN THESE TO EXIST IN THE SAME
SOCIETY THERE IS CAN BE A
SKETCH OF THE SOUL OF THE
SOCIETY BECAUSE THERE'S
DIFFERENT. AT AT THAT TABLE
ABOUT. THEY'RE REPRESENTING THE
KITCHEN TABLE NEEDS. KITCHEN
TABLE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THEY'RE THEY'RE
REPRESENTING THE BOARD
CONFERENCE ROOM TABLE THAT IS A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE AND
THAT'S WHY IT TAKES NOW IT
TAKES A GREAT DEAL AND I A COP
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
CORY. THE I WAS GOING THERE MAY
IT LIKE THERE. CHILDREN AND
OTHER PEOPLE NEED WORKING
FAMILIES WHICH COULDN'T BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. NOTHING
GETS OR EVIDENCE TO WHICH- AND
HOW THEY ARE CONDUCTING THIS
SELL IT AGAIN WE'LL WE BELIEVE
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY
TO FIND COMMON GROUND. YOU COME
COME DOWN A TRILLION GO UP
TRILLION AND WE CAN THAT HOW WE
DO THAT WITHOUT HURTING HER
BECAUSE WORKING FAMILIES THIS
MOSTLY ABOUT HOW LONG THAT THAT
COULD BE. INITIATIVE LAST IT'S
NOT A DIFFERENT PRIOR IT'S JUST
ABOUT SHORT PERIODS OF TIME.
YEAH MY RESPONSIBILITY COMMON
GROUND. BUT WHERE WE CAN'T. FOR
THE CHILDREN WE MUST STAND OUR
GROUND DEFINITELY SPEAKER
PELOSI FIRST YESTERDAY TWO
FANTASTIC I LIKE IT LIKE THAT.
SO REPUBLICAN HAVE BEEN SAYING
THAT. I ARE NOT WILLING TO GIVE
ANYTHING SO NOW YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE WILLING TO COME DOWN AND-
LAST NIGHT THEY DIDN'T BRING IT
UP. BUT THEY SAID HE HEARD AND
REJECTED AND IT TELLING THAT
RIGHT SO YOU'RE WILLING TO COME
DOWN TO TWO POINT FOUR TRUMP OR
LESS IT ALSO OPENCONGRESS. HE
WAS A CONGRESSMAN HE WAS ALWAYS
HE WAS A TEA PARTY FREEDOM
CAUCUS SOMEONE WHO IS THERE TO
BLOCK DEALS. DO YOU THINK THAT
HE IS NOT GETTING A- FACE. IS
POSITION ARE HEARTENED AND NON
COMPROMISING. MORE SO THAN
MNUCHIN. ONE AND TWO POINT FOUR
TRILLION YOU'RE WILLING TO COME
TO POINT HER TRAINER LEFT.
NANCY SAID WILL GO DOWN A
TRILLION FROM OUR TOP NUMBER
WHICH WE AND THEY'LL GO UP A
TRILLION REJECTED IT WE DIDN'T.
GO OVER. HERE'S WHERE I'M THERE
WERE DELETED ONE OUR REGIONAL
YOU COULD SAY. OR WHAT THREE
SEVEN DEPENDING ON. THE TYPE.
HELLO WE SUBJECT WE TAKE A WAY
OF REPEATING THE- OVER AT BUT
THIS ONE THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS- ATTACKS BANDAGE THEY
GAVE THE WEALTHIEST PEOPLE IN
OUR COUNTRY IN THE CASE THAT WE
WERE THAT. I THAT WE- ANOTHER
AS WELL SO WE TWO IF. IN THERE.
NOW IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
REPEAL THAT THEN OUR BILL IS
LIKE TWO SEVEN THREE RISK
ADJUSTMENT RECESSION. THE ONLY
THING THAT WOULD BE CLEARED
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT ONE. FOR
WHATEVER. WHAT ARE. FIFTY
OFFICER WOULD BE ENOUGH BILL TO
PASS THE NIGHT WITH OKAY THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THIS. SOME OF THINGS WE-
SEPTEMBER THIRTY SEPT THIRTIETH
TWO TWENTY ONE WE CAN ADJUST
THE DATE. YES SO. I DON'T THINK
THEY DID THAT ELEMENT OF BOTH
PASS ANY BILL THAT NORTH OF TWO
TRILLION DOLLARS ARE YOU AT ALL
OPEN TODAY IDEA GOING TO FIND
OUT MORE TO GET DOZEN. BECAUSE
OF THE TWO TRILLION. WILLIAM SO
THAT'S WHAT COMPROMISES ALL
ABOUT BECAUSE THERE ARE TWENTY
PUBLIC. VOTE FOR ANYTHING THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THE WHOLE THING
SHOULD SHIFT IN THERE. YEAH
MEETING THE- WHAT I SAID. WE
HAVE A VIRUS WHEN WE DID. THEY
ANTICIPATION IN THE HOPE WAS
THAT THEY WOULD EVENTUALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO SCIENCE AND THIS
WOULD BE DIMINISHING IT'S SIX
ALL RIGHT THIS VIRUS IS LIKELY
FREIGHT TRAIN. SO FAST. AT
RESPONDING LIKE A CONVOY GOING
AS SLOW AS THE SLOWEST SHIP IT
JUST DOESN'T WORK AND WHAT WE
PUT IN OUR BILL IS WHAT WE SAW
AS NECESSARY NOW. TO SAY I'D
CAN PEOPLE A LOT OF THE MAIN
BILL AND OF AGONY CHRISTIE AND
ALSO IT OVER AND OVER THIS IS.
OUR OF. THIS IS NOT JUST A-
GAME I MEAN YOU'RE ACTING LIKE
ALL THE- THIS. FEEDING KIDS
OPENING SCHOOL. EMPLOYING
PEOPLE HELPING PEOPLE WHO NEED
HELP THIS IS HAVING FAIR
ELECTIONS THESE ARE VERY
SUBSTANTIVE THINGS TO US AND WE
WILL TRY. TO MAKE SOMEWHERE AND
GET SOMETHING TO. NOT JUST THEY
WANT THEY WANT AT THE END. IT'S
REAL NEEDS THAT'S WHAT GOT.
WHAT SEEMS TO THIS IS THE IDEA
OF THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD LITTLE
MONEY POSSIBLE RIGHT THE- AT.
THAT AS I SAID LAST SOME OF YOU
AT THE VET SO HE'S- FOR ME FOR
CHOOSE A BURNER GOING TO HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO FEED EVERYONE
WE'RE NOT GOING HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO HEALTH. WE'RE NOT THE
MONEY TO THIS. WHAT AND THE WAY.
THE SCHOOL FROM APART BECAUSE-
HE GOING TO HAVE THE BULK OF
HIS MY GO TO SCHOOL THAT OPEN
THAT ARE OUT IN PERSON ACT BE
SET UP NOT TO THAT THE OTHER.
MANY THE ACTUAL OR- HYBRID
SCHOOL. OUR NEIGHBORHOOD THEY
DON'T DON'T HAVE A HIGH TAX
BREAKS. SO WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SAYS WE'RE CUTTING YOU OUT
THERE CUTTING OUT KIDS- TOTAL
ONE KIDS IN ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREA. SHE SOME OF.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY WAIT A
MINUTE THIS IS PERFORMED OF
AMERICA'S CHILDREN IT JUST
DOESN'T. LUCKY YOU A
CORONAVIRUS CAME ALONG HE LIVED
IN A HIGH END OF PROPERTY TAXES
SYRIA AT JUST REINFORCING
REINFORCING THE DISPARITY OF
TERM TO MEETING THOSE
CHILDREN'S NEEDS ENFORCING THE
DISPARITY IN TERMS OF HELP
DRESS CORONAVIRUS. HI AT THE I
CLICK EDIT THAT THEY ARE
SPRINGING FROM COMMITTEE OTHER
SELF THERE'S SO MANY IN JUST.
IN HERE A AND AGAIN AND
GRETCHEN THIS ALL OF THE
CHILDREN SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
THERE'S THE VIRUS FOR AT HOME
OR IN. AND MAKING OFF WITH YEAH
THREE GET THREE OKAY ONE MORE
MOMENT. DONALD TRUMP. FIFTY
ORDER ONE DEMOCRATS WANTED TO
NEGOTIATE ON ISSUE DEFENDING
THAT THE EXECUTIVE WE THAT I
ISSUES THAT AREA WHERE YOU WANT
TO NEGOTIATE IT IN. I'M NOT.
THANK YOU. TIM.